so this is just for weddings you guys
are looking for the cross lateral chest
okay
so it's not that he's going to stab me
but you'll pay attention more if that's
in that other that's in that you have to
take cami
Hey he said I'm always close enough
you
look I just can't bring that arm
hey so let's just let's just look at
this angle look what it's doing you
think what live at Kenzie STEMI why why
is that across my little check on that
it's not do you understand so you have
to do things to change me you're my
everything same thing
everything has to keep affecting this
shoulder so the same same thing on this
way why is this different yeah if you're
gonna do that one home well you got to
be out of range Louise don't have to
shoulder the back shoulder this is
what's an easy all the time boom boom
you guys just don't do it you just go
through the motion
[Music]
hey let's just
you
[Music]
it's movement to
hey hey we read yesterday I did Oh keep
your breath say here if I'm here like
this that arms gonna get me you know you
have to learn to move by moving it's a
mixture of both
it's a nice training all right maybe see
because but come back because his elbow
keep so far forward and that hands back
there I don't have to move go back but
if I'm here like this and I'm here like
that then I have to move right so I
don't know where you're gonna end up
just going to be rude up - yes you're
just always happen to awareness unless
we're right of that cross my little chat
so I want you to muscle it right you
still have a heart call like he taught
her to do right
you
that's a different thing
[Music]
you
so we're you know we just do I think I
think what happens is that the art was
practiced by was developed in a
different context in today's context and
then it was practiced by a lot of people
who had other martial artists experience
okay and so now it's become its own
thing the context is not there for most
people most people are not law
enforcement officers right they see you
would have a reason for or you know the
the the context of origin okay
and then a lot of people don't train in
other martial arts and then come to
Aikido so there's this kind of like
don't see I don't see the checks do you
get it
I don't understand the checking system
and it's a problem so we're trying to
bring some awareness there and you get
all kinds of weird things
what you do is still like on the first
move people like this time do you see
there's notes so if it was a punch or
something I'm not aware of it I don't
understand the corners of the fight I
don't really get that this same thing
like we were doing I was thinking you
see you see this kind of stuff all the
time it's not that it's for a knife
attack and a guy grabbing you but you
got no concept that you're on this
you're on the line of attack you're not
in the corners okay so the same thing it
is a result and get some weird-ass
things some weird-ass things like how is
this how is this a blending I just threw
you into me all right and if you were
bigger than me what would you actually
you know and I didn't have a face full
English
right okay so same thing here
see I if I don't have this idea people
tend to be here you see us all the time
and then they go like this we see fun so
what if I doing is I'm going around and
I'm I'm on the other side of the ninth
you see that huh okay now again as you
as you get up people go like this this
is easy
he used this man but I'm not no no
longer in there away from the knife okay
so get my angle translation there stay
away from the knife right he goes right
and I'm here so I'm I'm in back again do
you see that I don't do a chi ten where
I'm going to be in front of him you see
that
so the carton isn't backing him right
and then here's my technique right here
cut so you can't you can't just move
wherever you're always looking for
slight angle so if you look if I'm just
here how many fingers am i holding if I
stick it out my tongue you see you have
no idea right okay it might try my hand
guide you don't know but when I moved
here like this we'll see you know
exactly what I'm he's on his knees he's
from a lateral you see that so I'm gonna
be here hi okay and I find that again
bag techniques happens so why do we tend
to do that not only because we're
ignorant of the fight but it's easier to
when you take their body from the front
than to let them stand up and lead them
into that position right we all have a
problem doing that you see that so we
want to hurry up and get to the front so
you can throw that arm in there do you
understand
okay okay